obviously master politician but did you
try other jobs before politics oh you
try other things yeah my first I mowed
lawns I've done like 24 things to earn
money in my life mm-hmm
first I mowed lawns and then when I was
13 I got a job at this little grocery
store across the street from our house
and the guy was in his 70s and he was
back then that's a long time ago you
know so anyway he he was very
superstitious and it bothered him that I
was left-handed you know that the Latin
word for her left is sinistra so he
thought I was sinister somehow I was
going to be totally messed up and at the
time a lot of people believed that so he
insisted that I stack all the
merchandise in the grocery store with my
right hand which I did my best to do
until I was stacking these 88 cent jars
of Hellmann's mayonnaise they were huge
with my right hand and two of them fell
off on the floor and broke there is
nothing worse than Matt mayonnaise
shredded in glass you know yeah so I had
to go clean it all up yeah yeah that's
bad enough
yeah Danny told me he had to dock my pay
which was only $1 an hour at the time
wait a minute you were getting paid at
dollar an hour you know and he was gonna
dock your pay because you dropped
mayonnaise using the wrong hand correct
so I told him I was I was 13 he was 73
there was a little difference in the
power relations I said look I love
working here and you can have a left
handed grocery Boer boy for a dollar an
hour but you can't have a right handed
one for first
he laughed and he let me be left-handed
and even letting me open my next
enterprise which was a my first small
business effort I was running a used
comic book store which was nice of him
because he was selling new comic books
in the grocery store yeah but I had two
beautiful old trunks full of every comic
book I'd ever known ever had and they
were in perfect shape and they sold like
hotcakes and I made $150 and I thought I
was a multi-millionaire yeah what an a
dollar an hour that you probably thought
but it was a really stupid decision but
I looked brilliant at the time if I had
saved those comic books they probably
worth quarter-million dollars that I
don't all be collector's item so I'm not
sure it was smart but yeah I think she
didn't work out for you we're gonna take
a break much more with President Bill
Clinton we'll be right back
[Applause]
you